los desastres climáticos se
multiplicaron por cinco en el último
medio siglo y las pérdidas causadas por
siete esas son algunas de las
conclusiones a las que llegó el más
reciente informe de la organización
meteorológica mundial un perfecto y pp
tender el número de personas afectadas y
la pérdida económica es cada vez mayor
debido al aumento en la frecuencia e
intensidad de los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos y el cambio
climático
extreme water brands and climate change'
a pesar de que el panorama que plantea
el documento es alarmante la onu resaltó
la importancia de los avances
tecnológicos para la prevención
entonces gracias a la mejora de nuestro
servicio de alerta temprana hemos podido
tener una disminución de las víctimas en
este tipo de eventos pero la mala
noticia es que las pérdidas económicas
han crecido muy rápidamente es bien
además la onu se enfática en las
desigualdades globales pues en los
últimos 50 años los efectos del cambio
climático han cobrado 2 millones de
vidas de las que 90 por ciento han
ocurrido en países arroyo mientras que
el 60% del daño económico se dio en los
países más ricos másters estos desastres
afectan a todos en el mundo pero afectan
a las personas que viven en países en
vías de desarrollo de manera
desproporcional después por fin airplane
el informe llega en el marco de un
verano con desastres climáticos
evidentes como el huracán aidan eeuu el
huracán grace en mexico los incendios en
europa y en diferentes partes de américa
la 1 resaltó también que los desastres
climáticos dejaron 31 millones de
personas desplazadas durante el año
pasado un número no muy lejano a los 48
millones que fueron obligados a huir por
los conflictos a nivel mundial